[Music]
i am
incredibly excited for lynn's
directorial debut tictic boom
you are both a part of it and i would
really love to hear
what it was like being part of that
project and working with lynn on his
directorial date
we started right before copen we
were in rehearsals every day
dancing singing just being put through
the whole
musical theater works which i personally
but we both love it we love it we live
for that that's like playtime
um and then we started principal
photography and
i think got only a couple days in and
had to shut down the entire thing
and then we picked it back up in
september
and we had to go back into rehearsals
because it had been
months um and picked it up from there
but
it was it was challenging because of
covet
it was the first production we had done
since the lockdown
um rules were uh
very restrictive for cast and crew
for everyone involved but you know it
kind of made everyone have to go the
extra mile in order
to be there um but lin being the shining
light that he is
brought such an energy of joy and
playfulness and just excitement um
because he loves jonathan larson and he
loves tick tick boom and he's been
dreaming about this
for as long as he can remember so the
fact that he got to do it
it just that radiates that's a whole
other energy
and for us to be there with him we all
have our own connections i think with
jonathan larson and
it just felt like there were moments of
magic
um and he is a big reason why that was
yeah it was so much fun working with
lynn and
the second with vanessa said it was like
this child-like energy
of excitement and everyone was really
happy to be there
and also it was a bunch of musical
theater nerds
so it was like we do this thing and it
was really cool that lin did this thing
where like we like to sing
whatever we're doing so it's like
sitting at a table
and then we create like an entire song
to it but it was covent so we weren't
necessarily allowed to sing
on set unless we were filming and there
were there were coveted officers who
would come over
and like tell us hey you got to walk
this way or don't forget your mask and
we're like all
getting ready and like walking on the
set and lyn's like what get out
and then a code officer would come and
be like excuse me mr miranda
oh you're not allowed to sing on set and
i felt so bad for that guy because i was
like
dang you gotta tell lin manuel miranda
not to sing
that has to be the hardest but i was sad
because i feel like
because we were a bunch of theater nerds
like if we
could have been filming not during covid
oh my gosh the stuff that would have
been happening in between tapes and
setups like then we couldn't explore
that because
we weren't allowed to sing unless the
cameras were rolling
um but you know we made the best of it
and we're so
proud excited because it's a really
special film yeah